yeah and when welcome to this video
Pisco gambit okay what the heck is the
Pisco gambit why do you call yourself
something gambit and then play c3 stuff
I don't know yes playing is solid
opening him turn essentially asking the
question the bishop on g2 is really
better place than the bishop only seven
the answer is no but still the white
position is extremely solid so it's
nothing serious okay I didn't know what
let's just take them and put this on the
phone the song had to go back I think I
just though he M looxcie 197 trading
monta loops maybe I should have taken on
it three well it's not clear that I have
to but getting rid of an idea could be
good night e 2 B 3 and so on but ok this
this is fine I have two somewhat better
bishop not much but somewhat the night
comes to see for I might be able to do
something but seen ya do I want to take
it or not I can take play deform
this is actually an interesting move and
then Queen to c7 it's almost forcing the
Queen trade yeah this is not much but I
have to slightly better structure that
hold on the form there's something to
take note off 96 no he wants to play
Bishop f4 it seems haha ok but again I'm
just hoping that he plays it the slight
gamble no doesn't doesn't play it ok so
why does he put the pawn them don't
quite understand but ok let's see
okay so do i take now or play a form if
for looks better trying to fix this
weakness on a three
that's not a move I expected but it is
quite okay it's difficult to to do
something here maybe maybe this one it
could be a bit risky but then why do you
need to play like in a secondary move I
really don't understand sometimes the
other moves seem much more interesting
to me but I'm probably just having no
clue ok Knight b6 I just get the pawn or
what's going on I can't play Knight b6
Bishop b2
also is d3 it's also possible him
[Music]
I try to win this with Knight b6 without
losing my d3 porn maybe this is just not
possible that's absolutely time worried
that it might happen completely to now
he'll have to calculate so in such a
quick sent to the short time and he will
play every move immediately absolutely
immediately I thought that should be
good isn't it good
grab this okay I actually here right to
take the night which has no squares why
yeah yeah this is a sushi just a suicide
chef if you play in a complicated ending
play every move in half a second I mean
I don't know okay so and that wasn't all
that interesting is opening much much of
the most of it was trades and I was
always thinking I should be a bit more
comfortable here because of white
weaknesses and the weeks before square
and I have potentially the better bishop
but of course it should never be enough
to win a game so we got this ending and
I think he played it okay right this was
all fine and then there were more
instant move that that I didn't
understand are in g5 why do you play g5
exactly why not h5 or okay so nothing
probably not much going on okay I got
here a five and ten and again this was
also played innocently yeah if I've seen
strong and it's also a grid the engine
agree yes I have to play five and it
seems that i'm clearly better him i was
i was a bit unsure about this okay we
should just be should be fine I wasn't
ending this and f4 wasn't clear to me
but maybe I can really do just the same
and picking us up a okay this is very
good for Black Knight b6
yeah that'd be six I mean I thought we
should be tooled up it should be fine
then okay that that makes a lot of sense
but this also is good right yeah and t2
is winning yeah they're picking up all
the porns now yeah yeah i don't know i
think if you have three minutes left
after 45 min something went wrong in
this game ok guys thanks for watching